hey youtubers is Charlie so the flash
season 2 is out on blu-ray so I thought
I'd do giveaway but I also wanted to
explain some of the Mark Waid savat our
flash story so we'll start with that
then we'll do free stuff so if you don't
know who saboteur is he's one of like
the first big flash villains that wasn't
created by Geoff Johns or from the
Golden Age
he's somebody from the Mark Waid era he
was created by Mark Waid to be a
different type of villain than the flash
had faced before you know you go up
against villains that have Speed Force
powers but the way they contextualized
the Speed Force was very different
during savat arts run in the really
interesting thing you guys may have
watched the TV show if you haven't read
the comics from like way way back the
Speed Force didn't become a thing until
the 90s like the people that wrote the
flash comic over the years didn't start
using the idea of the Speed Force as a
way to explain the Flash's powers until
the 90s before that they just ran really
fast and it was like well how do they
explain why there's no friction like way
they don't burn the atmosphere off
there's all these logic problems so the
Speed Force like coming up with the idea
of the Speed Force was a way to deal
with that so the flash issue 108 Savitt
are debuts and it's wally west and all
the flash family his friends they've
just come through this big ordeal wally
west is thinking about getting married
to his love interests who's Linda Park
and they're like they're sitting there
just having this fun couples lunch when
all of a sudden Speed Force ninjas come
and it's like oh my god what the hell
Speed Force ninjas this doesn't make any
sense so Jay Garrick Jesse quake show up
and they're like something has happened
we don't have our speed anymore most of
you know Jesse quick uses the formula
like the Speed Force formula she speaks
it out loud that gives her her speed Jay
Garrick also runs fast but not quite as
fast as Wally West they show up and like
all their powers failed during these
really critical moments like they were
trying to take down villains in
different places and all of a sudden
speed just gets turned off they're a
bunch of people that use the Speed Force
powers villains and heroes in
simultaneously it's like someone flips
the switch and everybody can't run fast
anymore so everyone's like what the hell
so come to find out that Savitt R has a
way to steal speed but a lot of that has
to do with the way a person access
the speedforce so at this point in the
comics is very different from
present-day I don't know if they're
gonna do this on the TV show but the way
the comics presented this problem in the
90s was that Wally West had like this
direct bond with the Speed Force
so Savitt are was not able to steal his
speed but everybody else had kind of
like a roundabout way of accessing their
Speed Force powers so savage Hart was
able to steal speed from them so like
Jay Garrick Jesse quick everybody who
wasn't like the main version of the
flash lost their Speed Force powers but
the big twist of the first issue that
kind of led this up like oh my god who's
this new villain how can he do this how
can he steal speed from people is the
introduction of max mercury likes avatar
and Max mercury are old foes from a long
time ago but you're only learning about
it in issue 108 this hadn't happened in
the comics before this he has him strung
up in sabotage speaking like this cult
leader he has the Speed Force cult where
he's like we have a brotherhood of
speedsters you have brought too many
people in you've diluted the power you
like you've diluted our connection with
God and he speaks of the Speed Force as
if it's got like you know the more Speed
Force you have the more connection you
have with God so the whole idea here is
is that there's like a finite amount of
Speed Force and the more people that are
using it the less is available to each
individual person so imagine you have a
bunch of brothers and sisters or you
have like a big family with one bank
account in they're all taking money out
at ATMs all over town the pile of cash
available to each person becomes smaller
and smaller so Savitt are like all
villains wants it all for himself so he
tries to start killing off other
speedsters so that he has all of the
available Speed Force so the whole savat
our Ark is about Wally West learning how
the Speed Force works the idea that the
Speed Force itself is not a myth and
that is the source of the Flash's powers
remember Jay Garrick the other
speedsters have no idea that the Speed
Force exists they just know that they
run fast but they don't have the broader
understanding of it thats avatar does
like he knows how to use it in ways that
Jay Garrick that Wally West that the
other speedsters don't know so
of course eventually Wally West is able
to defeat him but he you know he gives
avatar what he wants as a way to defeat
him like remember the first episode of
flash season 2 where Barry goes up
against atom smasher remember the way
they defeated him he absorbed radiation
that's what gave him his powers so
Caitlin has the idea to just bombard him
with too much radiation and it ends up
killing him that's kind of how Wally
defeats avatar in the comics so he takes
him to the edge of speed like you know
faster than he's ever been before in
savat are just completely vaporizes into
pure energy because he absorbs too much
Speed Force so high-fives all around
that's that guess we'll never see him
again
well you remember this is the comics no
one who appears to die ever truly dies
so savat are ends up coming back later
during the flash rebirth which is a
Geoff Johns title but we can talk more
about him later in the story like after
Wally West when we see the flash season
3 I'll be interested to see how close
they stick to the comic book plot like
maybe Harrison wells earth-1 Harrison
wells will be like the max mercury of
the story the person who kind of
introduces Savatage to the idea gets him
hooked and then savage har goes off and
creates this evil cult research doing
terrible things but as you can see
there's a lot of different characters
that the flash TV show has now Jesse
quick doesn't have her powers yet
probably gonna get power sometime this
season
so it actually probably pretty helpful
for you guys to read that savat are run
but I'll talk about it as we get
episodes if they do comic book things
from that story what they might end up
doing though is they might incorporate
some rebirth storyline stuff into this
the reverse flash kind of poisons Barry
so that when he runs he poisons other
people killing them off so you have like
the reverse Speed Force like evil speed
force we might see some of that this
season and that'll be like the way of
explaining evil speed force wormhole
aliens but that gets into like Star Trek
Deep Space 9 stuff flash rebirth sup so
I don't want to get too far ahead of the
story we'll have to see what they end up
doing but let me know in the comments
how close do you think they're gonna
stick to the comic book story even if
you haven't read the comic book story
they always change little elements but
I'm expecting lots of Easter eggs for
Star Trek Deep Space 9 Easter
for the sabotage storyline during mark
Wade's run Easter eggs for flash rebirth
so that doesn't even really get into the
idea of the rival he might take the
place of eobard thawne during flash
rebirth but nobody can replace the
reverse flash the reverse flash is
definitely here we're doing flashpoint
in the beginning so they're jumping all
over the place so I'm expecting the
rival whatever ends up happening with
Savitt are I'm expecting the rival to
stick around for most of the season the
actor that they cast is actually you
know relatively big in terms of CW shows
so even though he's not going to be in
every single episode he will still be a
big villain in the back half but make no
mistake Sava Tarr is like the main
villain of the season he's like the
biggest threat of all but the good news
is is that there is a new round of the
DC giveaway in because the flash season
2 is that on blu-ray today that's what
the giveaway is for so it's like an
Amazon gift card for the value of the
blu-ray which is like 20 or 30 dollars
whatever the price of the blu-ray is so
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll be posting more DC videos this week
so I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so get hype
the blu-ray itself just has the same
type of bonus features that previous
seasons have had like it has deleted
scenes
it has bloopers so later tonight Lee
just announced a whole bunch of Luke
Cage stuff so it'll either be Luke Cage
or Thor Ragnarok I keep meaning to make
Thor Ragnarok lots of Marvel lots of DC
stuff happening it's gonna be a really
good week even though people are back in
school and that kind of sucks a little
bit there's still a whole bunch of
awesome stuff happening what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn about Justice League movie
characters coming onto the TV shows you
can click here to learn all about
shocker and spider-man homecoming thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight